it really wasn't gonna do a video on
this because what is this trailer really
it's a super short really vague Aladdin
trailer with nostalgic music what was
the last trailer for Aladdin a super
short really vague Aladdin trailer with
nostalgic music only this time we get to
see Will Smith as blue Genie not like
Entertainment Weekly cover genie which
he seemed really pumped about do people
still talk [ __ ] that's Disney being in a
tough spot I guess you show Will Smith
as the genie not blue people are pissed
he's not blue you show Will Smith as
blue genie people are like he looks like
[ __ ] what to do well I don't know but
for my part my what to do is to talk
about it so this trailer for Aladdin
alright what I liked about it was the
scenery the scenery looks nice that
looks like a painting I know that scene
I liked those shots and really when this
trailer ended I wasn't even thinking
about Will Smith's genie or bad CGI
genie rather I'm thinking about your far
bring me the map that's the best bring
me the lamp if it's convenient to you I
don't want to be late for my weekly
Netflix binge sure thing man the
animation just sounds more intense bring
me the lamp
bring me the lamp gold makes the rules I
don't know what I was expecting Jafar
doesn't always have a menacing voice
like yes I don't know if someone with
that tongue was like bring me the laugh
I mean like yeah go [ __ ] yourself and
keep it for myself what are you gonna do
can't help it sue me you know that
sounded like [ __ ] then Will Smith Genie
which alright anybody who took on the
role of the genie would have impossible
shoes to fill not huge shoes to fill
impossible to use the film Will Smith
was like I'll do it yeah so genies he's
blue he's also CGI which is fine Thanos
with CGI but also that's why it's a
problem cuz we saw a nose we all knew or
at least assumed the genie would be CGI
but we also figured it would be good CGI
that's the thing about CGI CGI has to
step up its game if you're gonna have a
CGI character especially a CGI character
in a movie that's otherwise generally
live-action is very noticeable and we've
experienced movies that have hidden it
very well they've blended the
live-action and CGI very well this
doesn't look as good granted there's
still time to fix it right I don't know
in three months what can they do in
three months is that enough time to
polish it make it look good I don't know
in one hand I'm kind of apprehensive to
judge too harshly at this point because
Will Smith is charming he could totally
crush it I realize yeah he was a lot of
fun to see his the genie may be Jafar
other than the one line I got in this
trailer maybe I'll be like now it was
really good he was really menacing I
wouldn't cross that dude for anything
for a trailer for a movie that comes out
in about three months I feel like this
is actually Disney going this is the
best we got this is the best we got to
pitch people and the fact that this
Aladdin movie is gonna be awesome and so
far I'm like I know I give a [ __ ] about
this blanking looks solid
let's defer to the director I like
snatch nearly twenty years ago so I
don't know what that means enough that
this trailer didn't win me over the last
trailer was way too vague this trailer
was too vague but the things they showed
didn't sell me and the genie looks like
[ __ ] CGI let's be honest your Disney
don't tell me you don't have the budget
to make it look good
stop it I think the gripes are justified
people are scared the genies an iconic
character from a lot of people's
childhoods dare I argue some people are
starting to think maybe they shouldn't
have done a live-action Aladdin movie
other people are thinking yeah I've
always thought they shouldn't do a
live-action Aladdin movie but in the end
it's easy to speculate as to what the
movie may or may not be but if we're
keeping it in the realm of reality as to
what the trailer actually is trailers
it's not that great right this trailer a
sneak peek or whatever it's a trailer or
the live-action Aladdin have you seen it
what you think about it and what do you
think of a genie and hysts look whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]